12 senate republicans say they will join
house republicans in challenging
electoral votes
two republican senators fight for their
lives in georgia and the new york times
cheers on a hit job against a 15 year
old girl
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data online with the vpn i
trust visit expressvpn.com
ben speaking of which social media
companies yeah they think that you
shouldn't be able to decide what
information you can and cannot see this
is something we found out throughout
last year so why exactly would you give
them your data so that you could then
have that data monetized against all of
your interests instead why not protect
your data the way that i do with express
vpn one big problem with big tech
companies not only do they censor what
you read they will actually track what
you do online
they track what you're searching for the
videos you watch everything you click
they use
that data to serve you ads they can
match your activity to your offline
identity using your device's unique ip
address
when i use expressvpn these tech
companies can no longer see my ip
address because my identity is masked
and anonymized by a secure vpn server
plus
expressvpn also encrypts 100 of your
data to protect you
from hackers and internet bad guys which
is a pretty important thing
it's not complicated by the way you can
just download the app and you put it on
your devices and you hit one button and
it's good to go i mean your grandmother
could do it why give tech companies a
free license to know everything about
you and then turn around and sell off
your information instead take back your
privacy at expressvpn.com
visit my special link get an extra three
months of expressvpn service for free
it's a great way to get the new year
started off right by protecting yourself
go to expressvpn.compr.essvpn.com to
protect your data
today okay so we are back and better
than ever it's a brand new year
and surely this year cannot be stupider
than the last year
yeah so about that
so many things have happened while i was
out
aside from my children badgering me and
aside from me not getting
enough sleep as i as i should have over
the break it turns out many stupid
things
happened over the course of the of the
break perhaps the stupidest
was this thing that happened in congress
yesterday i'm just gonna mention this
briefly because
it is indicative of where this year is
going and then we'll get to the actual
big news stories
of the day so yesterday congress opened
with a prayer
the prayer with which congress opened is
i believe the stupidest thing i have
ever heard in all my life
in all my life and i've heard many
stupid things i mean i literally do a
political talk show
so i hear stupid things on a daily basis
so yesterday
the the person who opens with the
opening prayer democratic congress
obviously opens by saying
this we ask it in the name of the
monotheistic god
brahma and god known by many
names by many different faiths
amen and a woman
so just to be straight this human said
amen
and a women and now as the designated
jew in your political life let me just
remind you as
a hebrew speaker the word amen is not an
english word
it comes from the hebrew word amen which
you say after prayers
which can originally be traced
etymologically speaking to the word
ahmet
which means truth the idea of amen is
solidarity that may it be so
or it's true that's what amane means it
was then
brought into greek and latin and then
passed along to english
the word amen has literally nothing to
do
with gender it does not mean a man
it means amen in other words it is a
sign it's like hallelujah right it's a
sign of solidarity
right that's that's what it is is an
exclamation and yet somehow
leftists have decided that the term amen
because it is spelled
a-m-e-n and includes the word men
somehow is gendered language and so we
are also supposed to say after prayers
a women so a few things one
number one not only is that radically
stupid
on an etymological level i mean you
would have to take the word amen take it
down to the pit of despair from the
princess bride
put the torture machine on it and
torture it until it tosses out some sort
of
gendered variant not only is that stupid
on that level
it would also then be meaningless why
would you end a prayer
any prayer and then just say man like
what that doesn't make any sense at all
it's idiotic beyond that it's doubly
idiotic
because it turns out that people on the
left don't actually believe that men and
women
are real concepts right they're
malleable
men and women so what they really should
say just to be tolerant is not amen
and a women they should say amen a women
and a gender is a social construct that
is unconnected to biological sex but
also a biological imperative
and then bow their heads that's where
that should end
so well done all the way through
everybody that's uh
that's a great way to start the year and
i think that the year can only
get dumber from here unfortunately okay
so
over the weekend huge news breaks from
the washington post the huge news that
breaks from the washington post is this
phone call
that president trump and his chief of
staff mark meadows had
with brad raffensberger who is the
georgia secretary of state
and is an hour long phone call the
washington post originally released
about a four minute segment of it then
they released the entire
transcript and the entire phone call and
it's not great
when i say it's not great i think it's
not great for for several reasons
i'm gonna explain what it is and one and
what it is not so we're gonna play just
a couple of clips from
this hour-long phone call because they
give you an idea of what the phone call
is
basically it runs along a couple of
tracks one is the president saying a lot
of things about georgia voting
that are unsubstantiated by evidence to
this point
he says the tens of thousands of dead
people voted in georgia there's not
evidence to that effect he says
that dominion machines are rigged
there's not evidence to that effect he
says a lot of things
that are just not substantiated by the
evidence is that his track one it's just
him
throwing out a bunch of things that he's
heard about the irregularities and voter
fraud
in georgia and brad raffensberger the
secretary of state saying that's that's
bad
information that is track number one
then there's track number two
and track number two is the president
saying that repeat and he says this
repeatedly
that he wants georgia to basically
re-jigger their calculation so that he
won the state
so a lot of people are reading that
statement as though trump is trying to
blackmail the secretary of state of
georgia into manufacturing votes
that he wins the state but the two
statements are related in other words
trump believes that there was widespread
voter fraud and voter regularity in
georgia again he has not provided proofs
to that effect i believe that there is
an ongoing court case to that effect
even if he were to flip it in georgia by
the way it wouldn't shift the outcome of
the election because pennsylvania
wisconsin
arizona et cetera but say for example
that
you know all that were brought in court
you can make those allegations in court
but many of the things that he has
alleged
have not actually been proved the
evidence has not been provided what he
is saying in this call over and over
again
is the same thing that trump always says
which is he has a bunch of ideas
he spews them out right in a sort of
garbled fashion
and then he finishes up by saying here's
what i want it's the same thing as the
ukraine phone call
a bunch of ideas about joe biden and
about burisma and about hunter biden
he was not making threats okay there's
not evidence here that he actually
threatened raffensberger with anything
right he doesn't have the power to
threaten raffensberger with anything
because raffensberger hasn't committed a
crime
when he says things like you're taking a
big political risk that happens to be
true
right i mean it is a big political risk
for raffensburger this has been true
since trump decided to basically contest
the georgia election
but there are some things that are true
about this call and some things that are
false about the call
okay so we'll play a couple of clips of
it then i'll explain what is true about
the column what is false about the call
and then we'll get to the broader issue
which is that republicans uh as
of as of wednesday are now planning some
republicans in the senate are planning
to challenge electoral college results
we'll get to that in just one second
here let's play the phone call first so
here was president trump with brad
raffensberger talking about dominion
voting systems
now do you think it's possible that they
uh shredded
ballots in uh fulton county because
that's what the rumor is
and also that dominion took out machines
uh that dominion is really moving fast
to get rid of their
uh machinery do you know anything about
that
because that's illegal that's ryan
germany no dominion has not
moved any machinery out of fulton county
we're having no but no but but if they
move
have they have they moved the inner
parts of the machines
and replaced them with other parts
no is yours ryan
i'm sure okay so as you can tell it's
not that trump is like very thoroughly
prepared when it comes to dominion he's
heard some things again this is not a
shock this is how trump has operated
literally his entire political career
is that he hears a thing he then
puts it out of his mouth and it is a
different thing right
so he says have you guys been shipping
into minion voting machines
and raffensburger guy says no
no machines have been shipped out of
state and they said well have you taken
parts out of dominion voting machines
and
we're now in the realm of things that
are unevidenced okay so that is line one
then
there's line two and this is the stuff
the media is really going crazy over and
that is
trump repeatedly talking about the
number of votes by which he lost
georgia right so he says what are we
going to do here folks i only need 11
000 votes
fellas i need 11 000 votes give me a
break so look
all i want to do is this i just want to
find
uh eleven thousand seven hundred and
eighty
votes which is one more that we have
because we won the state so as you hear
there he says look all i want to do is
this i just want to find 11
780 votes which is one more than we have
because we won the state okay so what
the media are saying he is saying
is that he is saying to raffensberger i
want you to manufacture those votes out
of thin air
and i don't care whether there was voter
fraud or voter irregularity
i want you to go under your bed and i
want you to find votes for donald trump
and then i want you to re-tally
that's not what trump is saying all
right what trump is saying is he
believes that there was widespread voter
fraud and voter irregularity undoubtedly
there was more voter fraud and voter
irregularity than the margin of victory
for joe biden in the state
and therefore he should be declared the
winner of the state he's not ordering
ralphensburger
to to manufacture votes out of thin air
he's not ordering raphensburger to
magically come up with 12 000 votes
that's not what he's doing it's bad
enough what he's doing now the reason
it's bad enough what he's doing
is because if you actually care about
voter fraud and voter irregularity you
shouldn't be tying that to results
what you should say is i'm concerned
about voter fraud i'm concerned about
voter irregularity there are a bunch of
outstanding allegations that have been
made that you have not answered
and so i want specific answers on those
not because the margin of victory
is the key issue not because i want you
to get to that 12 000 votes and flip the
state but because i care about voter
fraud and voter irregularities so for
people who seriously want to reject
the system it can't be a self-interested
pursuit it can't be i care about voter
fraud and voter irregularity
because it hurt me it has to be i care
about voter fraud and voter irregularity
generally right that is the biggest
problem with trump's phone call
the specter of a of a candidate in an
election calling up the election
official as president of the united
states
and telling him that he is upset that
the margin
is is 11 000 votes and that he doesn't
really care how about the voter fraud
voter regularity all he cares about is
the margin
that's ugly stuff is that criminal stuff
no people people who are suggesting that
this is criminal activity that's silly
it's not criminal activity
people who are suggesting that trump is
quote unquote threatening raffensberger
i read the entire transcript
there really is not evidence of
threatening behavior by trump you can
say there's a power imbalance in the
conversation that's certainly true
it's certainly true that when the
president calls you up and says he wants
you to find a thing that you feel
pressure to find the thing
that does not mean that there's an
actual attempt by trump to actually
punish raffensberger and other
in any way other than the sort of
overtly political yelling at
raffensberger which he's been doing
for months since the since the election
itself
okay so that was the big story last
night is the tape and people suggesting
that trump was trying to get
raffensburger to manufacture votes that
part of the story is not true it doesn't
mean the phone call was good again
kind of like ukraine the phone call can
be bad and also it cannot be what the
media is is saying
that the phone call is okay in just a
second we're gonna get to the the
broader issue right because the phone
call
is off to the side and somewhat
irrelevant to the broader issue
of what congress is going to do on
january 6. we're going to go through the
entire process
we're going to talk about what various
congress people and senators
are talking about doing right now we'll
get to that in just one moment first
since the beginning of the pandemic
petsmart has remained open
making sure that you can get everything
your pet needs right when you need it
over 1 600
convenient locations if you got a pet
you got to keep it healthy we have
the daily wire pet jasper the most
incredible of all dogs
you know how i know that jasper is such
an incredible dog because jasper cannot
see me for months
recognize me and then growl at me and
jasper knows
his enemies but jasper also knows his
friends which is why his master jeremy
boring
will bring jasper to petsmart and get
jasper the stuff that jasper needs
right now petsmart is offering free
same-day delivery powered by doordash
through january 31st you get everything
your pet needs right to your door and
right when you need it petsmart stores
and grooming salons offer digital
check-in curbside drop off and pick up
contact list payments so they are as
safe as safe can be petsmart's
associates really love pets caring for
them is a big part of why they work
there and petsmart has made it safe and
easy for you to care for your pet too
online or in stores if you're interested
in contactless shopping just order
online at petsmart.com
or on the petsmart app and enjoy easy
curbside pickup or free same day
delivery powered by doordash through
january 31st go to petsmart.com
for more details because petsmart is not
just pet friendly they have great prices
they have fantastic service and they
take care
of every pet like they were jasper the
company dog of the daily water check out
petsmart.com
for more details today okay so
meanwhile the big story through the week
is not gonna be this trump tape which is
going to disappear into the ether
as far as people who care about it
within the next 48 hours the media are
going to try and blow it into
trump did something quote unquote
impeachable or he committed some sort of
criminal offense
no again a thing can be bad it can be
immoral without the thing
being criminal or impeachable okay but
the the bigger question is what's going
to happen
on wednesday so just to set the stage
the way that this typically works okay
the actual process under the electoral
count act is that and the the electoral
contact was created in 1887 i'll explain
the background in just a second
the way that this works is that members
of congress are empowered to object to
individual state electoral college
returns
and this is the congressional research
service summing up the electoral college
act as it currently stands quote
objections to individual state returns
must be made in writing by at least one
member each
of the senate and house of
representatives if an objection meets
these requirements the joint session
recesses and the two houses
separate and debate the question in
their respective chambers for a maximum
of two hours right you have
the house goes to one side the senate
goes to the other side they yell at each
other
about whether these electoral college
votes should be counted the two votes
the two houses then vote separately to
accept or reject the objection
and then reassemble in joint session and
announce the results of their respective
votes
and objections to the state's electoral
votes must be approved by both houses
in order for any contested votes to be
excluded
so on what grounds can you challenge
electoral college votes
well you can challenge on two grounds
one that they were not regularly given
right that's the language of the statute
or two that the electors were not quote
unquote lawfully certified
so regularly given means that the
elector was bribed or fraudulent
right that's what regularly given means
that we find out that an elector
was supposed to vote for donald trump
and voted for joe biden because hunter
slipped him
cocaine or something right and then
lawfully certified means that the
governor
has to actually certify the
ascertainment process
right so lawfully certified just means
that the governor did what he's supposed
to do
and if it was not lawfully certified
then the house can debate this sort of
stuff
under those particular challenges
electors would then be discarded
and uh and that would change the math
necessary for victory
and now it is not unprecedented for
these things these challenges to happen
it is unprecedented for the size and
scope of the challenge now being
contemplated by the republicans to
happen it gets that in a second but
it's not unprecedented back in 2005
january 6 2005 according to cnn
alleging widespread irregularities on
election day a group of democrats in
congress objected thursday to the
counting of ohio's 20 electoral votes
delaying the official certification of
the 2004 presidential election results
the move was not designed to overturn
the re-election of president bush said
ohio representatives stephanie tubbs
jones and california senator barbara
boxer who filed
the objection the objecting democrats
said they wanted to draw attention to
the need for aggressive election reform
in the wake of what they said were
widespread of voter problems in ohio
the house of representatives and senate
met this is again 2005
and a constitutionally mandated session
to count the electoral votes vice
president dick cheney
presided over the session the results
from each state read in alphabetical
order were ticked through quickly until
ohio was called and then a clerk wrote a
letter
from boxer and tubbs jones and then the
chambers had a split and then they
argued about
each other or with each other and then
they came back together and that was
sort of the end
of that particular process now it is
worth noting
that there was fairly significant if not
support
then tacit unwillingness to shut down
barbara boxer by some top democrats
now it is true john kerry who is the
candidate for the democrats
disassociated himself from the suffering
he said listen the election's over
challenging the electoral votes is
useless there's no reason to do this but
among people who went silent james
clyburn who's now the majority whip for
the democrats
this is nathan werzel reporting frank
pallone now chairman of energy and comm
and commerce committee maxine waters
who's chairwoman of financial services
ed markey who's now senator and john
lewis
right so there was some support for this
or at least tacit support
for this process back in 2005.
now barbara boxer of course is claiming
there is no comparison now there
absolutely is a comparison barbara boxer
was the dumbest member of the united
states senate until her retirement
uh she has not gained an intelligence
since leaving office here was barbara
boxer on cnn the other day
well there's no comparison to what
congresswoman stephanie tubbs jones and
i did
in o5 number one
john kerry had conceded the race we have
a president here who's orchestrating
kind of an overthrow of the election
secondly we set up front
we had no interest we said upfront
we had no interest in overturning the
election
all we wanted was to focus on voter
suppression that we
saw in ohio okay but that of course is
not true the only reason that they
challenged the electoral results in ohio
is because they wanted to focus on
overturning
the election okay so there is precedent
for this is there precedent for the
candidate themselves to support this
effort
no not really at least not for 140 years
or so
is there a precedent for large swaths of
congress backing this sort of effort no
there is not so that is in fact
unprecedented so it's not unprecedented
for this sort of thing to happen it's
not unprecedented for these challenges
to happen it happened in 1969 about the
68 election
it happened again in 2005 but for this
level of support to be thrown behind it
that is somewhat unprecedented so we're
going to go through the legality here
because i know there's a big debate here
on the right
about what is legal and what is not what
the constitution is designed to do
how you count electoral votes we're
going to go through all the details in
just
one second so you know more than you did
before this show began
first let us talk about your future and
your specific goals so one of the things
that you probably are thinking about in
the middle of this difficult and dark
time
is getting your resume in order because
hopefully in the next few months the
economy is really going to spike
as the vaccine hits as jobs become
available why not get that resume in
order right now and get a better salary
and get a better job this is why you
need
to think about the university of arizona
global campus university of arizona
global's
global campuses online bachelors and
master's degree programs
allow you to learn on a convenient and
flexible schedule at uagc
expert faculty teach you real-world
skills from real world experience and
online
classes built for life twists and turns
you can learn from home or wherever you
happen to feel comfortable you can
pursue a degree
in one of the uagc's 60 plus programs
like business administration
health care administration and
psychology with 24 7 access to your
classroom daily support financial aid
available
uagc will give you the tools that you
need to go from dreaming
to doing and you may very well need a
degree for that job that you are
thinking about applying for so go check
them out
right now your bigger future starts
today university of arizona global
campus no fee to apply
no standardized testing required to
enroll go to uagc.edu slash ben that is
uagc.edu
ben uagc.edu ben not all programs
available
in all states okay so let's do a little
bit of background here about what the
electoral college certification process
is supposed to do
and why it currently is constituted the
way that it is constituted
so the constitution of the united states
says this this is
from the 12th amendment it says the
president of the senate shall in the
presence of the senate and house of
representatives
open all the certificates and the votes
shall then be counted okay so we'll stop
right there for just a second because
there are some people who are now
claiming
that vice president mike pence is
supposed to
somehow not count the votes that it's
his job to determine whether the votes
are legit and then just not count the
votes that he doesn't like
that is not legally based okay the the
vice president does not have the power
to do that that would be ridiculous like
on just a normal constitutional level
the idea of the vice president being
able to unilaterally decide who
is president is totally crazy
particularly when you're talking about
the vice president very often being on
the same ticket as a person who is
running
right can you imagine back in 2004
dick cheney just deciding you know what
i preside over the senate guess what
bush one don't even have to count the
votes can you imagine
in in 1980 jimmy carter's vice president
just saying you know what
my job to count the votes my job you
know what jimmy won
sure he lost but he won right it would
be crazy to have like that is not the
constitutional system that is not the
constitutional
structure that's clearly not the intent
of the constitution
okay so by the way worthy of mention
here is lynnwood so lynn wood who's this
lawyer from georgia who's been
he was part of the original kraken team
and all of this kind of stuff
linwood's a crazy person and not only
has been telling people not to vote in
the georgia senate runoff which we'll
get to in a little bit
he is now suggesting that vice president
pence is going to be in jail
hey i'm just going to point out that if
you're paying attention to lynn wood at
this point you're
you're being i don't know what to tell
you he's crazy okay he tweeted out over
the weekend
if pence is arrested secretary of state
mike pompeo will save the election
pence will be in jail awaiting trial for
treason he will face execution by firing
squad
he is a coward and will sing like a bird
and confess all
okay other things that linwood has
tweeted over the past 24 hours quote
i believe chief justice john roberts and
a multitude of powerful individuals
worldwide are being blackmailed in a
horrendous scheme involving rape and
murder of children captured on videotape
i have the key to the files containing
the videos i've also shared this
information
this blackmail scheme is conducted by
members of the ten of ten of the world's
most well-known and elite
intelligence agencies one of those
groups was hacked by a group known as
lizard squad the black blackmail files
of rape and murder were obtained by this
group and copy was provided
to isaac cappy after cappy received the
hack files
from members of lizard squad he gave
files to one friend and the encryption
key to another friend he provided this
information to his friends shortly
before he was murdered
in may 13th 2019. members of lizard
squad were jailed for hacking
jeffrey epstein used this game blackmail
the same blackmail scheme of child rape
and child murder to either further his
own interests or those of any
intelligence agency
with whom he worked um
yeah uh okay so it that's lynnwood
so i'm gonna go with not linwood's legal
analysis other legal analysis that is
not very good peter navarro who's the
president's
special trade representative said on fox
that mike pence has the power to delay
the inauguration
he does not this is not correct and by
the way if january 20th arrived and joe
biden had not actually been designated
the president
elect of the united states beforehand
you know who'd become president
trump doesn't just keep being president
on january 20th if the office is vacant
then the house of representatives decide
who's president so get ready for
president pelosi if this is actually
how you think it's going to go so i'm
just pointing out the bad legal analysis
so you know where it is here's peter
navarro
who is is not a good lawyer vice
president pence he has the authority to
give that 10-day window
to do what needs to get done and i
cannot imagine when he looks at the
facts
he won't vote vote the right way on that
and you know peter the interesting thing
is that that 10-day window
uh is it it is something that they can
change the date uh
the the first uh january 20th cannot be
changed that's constitutional but
this whole certification thing that they
said well they can be changed
actually past that date we can go past
that date
we can go past that date um if we need
to
no you can't okay so what is the actual
process
we're going to get to the actual process
and what is now being challenged right
josh halley
ted cruz uh a bunch of republican
senators are jumping on board we'll get
to the legal analysis here because it's
become quite controversial
and it's become quite controversial
because i think some people are trying
to politically make this into some sort
of litmus test
it is not in fact a litmus test the
legal analysis here
is is i think pretty faulty and
strategically speaking it is not going
to end with with trump
being retained as president of the
united states there's literally no way
for that to happen
under the current process it's just not
on even if it
even if it were legal it would not be
effective okay so we're gonna get to
that in one second i'm gonna analyze the
whole
issue for you we'll go through all the
arguments because people who i really
respect on on the legal side
are making counter arguments we'll go
through all of them so you'll have all
the information at your disposal
first let us talk about the fact that a
good new year's resolution would be not
going to the post office for tasks you
can complete from home
first of all you're spending a lot of
time second of all you're going to be
standing
in line you really don't need to do all
of those things i mean if if we
learned one thing in 2020 it's that you
can do a lot of things online
just as well as you can do it in person
sometimes better stamps.com better to do
it online
than in person the reason because with
stamps.com you get the services of the
post office and ups
directly on your computer plus giant
discounts on mailing and shipping rates
here at daily wire we've been using
stamps.com since 2017.
no more wasting our time sending some
sort of gopher to the post office to
schlep boxes that's not a thing that we
are going to do instead we use
stamps.com stamps.com brings the
services of the us postal service and
ups
directly to your computer wherever you
are stamps.com it's a must-have for any
business whether you're a small office
sending out invoices an online seller
shipping out orders even a giant
warehouse
sending thousands of packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pick up or drop it off it is that simple
with stamps.com you get five cents off
every first class stamp up to 40
off priority mail up to 62 off ups
shipping rates
not to mention it is a fraction of the
cost of those expensive postage meters
stamps.com it's a no-brainer it saves
you time it saves you money it's no
wonder over 900 000 small businesses
already use stamps.com so
make 2020 the year you stop wasting your
time and head on over to stamps.com
instead no risk with my promo code
shapiro yet a special offer includes a
four week trial plus
free postage and digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts
just head on over to stamps.com click on
the mic at the top of the homepage type
in shapiro that is stamps.com
promo code shapirostamps.com never go to
the post office
again alrighty so now let's go through
the actual electoral college process so
i've told you
about how challenges take place under
the electoral college act you need to
know the history
of the electoral college act to know
what we are attempting to avoid
okay so the reason that the electoral
college act was originally
passed i'm gonna give you all the legal
background on all the relevant laws and
then you can decide for yourself whether
you think there's a good effort or a bad
effort or a malign effort
okay we'll get to okay so let's begin
with the 1876 election so the
constitution is actually
not particularly clear on what happens
if there is controversy within a state
sufficient that the electors that
separate slates of electors are sent to
congress so here's what happened in 1876
right remember this is only
about a decade after the end of the
civil war
so the prospect of violence is still
very real there's still very large scale
questions about voter suppression
and voter fraud particularly in the
south okay so
it's an election between rutherford
hayes rutherford b hayes who's the
republican and samuel tilden
who is the democrat so hayes support is
entirely northern with the exception of
new york which went for samuel tilden
because new york had uh some
fairly severe feelings about race
obviously that were pretty
wrong and despicable copperheads were
big in new york
so samuel tilden wins new york and in
the south
there are a bunch of states that are in
controversy because it's pretty obvious
that the south is
very much in favor of samuel tilden the
democrat but a lot of people
can't vote uh a lot of people uh ha that
there are carpet baggers like
there's some real problems of voter
irregularity and there are serious
questions as to who really should be
able to vote considering that 11 years
earlier a lot of these people were
literally
fighting each other in the streets okay
so during that election during the 1876
election multiple southern states
actually sent several competing slates
of electors republicans claimed in those
southern states that voter intimidation
and fraud
had been the reason that tilden was
declared the victor in places like
louisiana and south carolina
tilden had won the popular vote by over
a quarter million votes nationwide
he did not have an electoral college
majority he was stuck at 184 electoral
votes at the time he needed 185 to win
rutherford hayes had 165 electoral votes
so
basically what would happen is that
multiple slates of electors were now
being sent
from these states so the state
legislature would send a slate of
electors they would say okay tilden
won the state we're sending our electors
over to congress
and then the republican governor would
be like nope sending my own slate of
electors because of voter fraud and
voter intimidation
i don't believe the voter outcome i'm
sending my own slate of electors
okay so there would actually be two
somewhat legitimate
competing sources of slates of electors
in 1876.
democrats at the time controlled the
house of representatives republicans
controlled the senate
hayes supporters or republicans argued
that the vice president should count the
votes under the constitution
and disregard slates he didn't like
right this is the issue that we were
discussing before
the two sides instead agreed to set up a
special committee charged with
developing a way of solving the issue
the senate voted
47-17 in favor of this the house did the
same 191-86
the way that this committee worked is
that five representatives were selected
by the house
five senators were selected by the
senate four supreme court justices were
named and then a fifth supreme court
justice would be selected by the other
force they came up with the committee
five members of the house five senators
five supreme court justices
democrats argued that every single
election should be investigated
republicans argued instead that
governor's certification
was the final word democrats then tried
to filibuster vote counts from nearly
every state
eventually democrats basically just gave
in because the committee
came down and found that the slates of
electors from the governors should be
respected the real
outcome here was not solved by the
commission okay it was not solved by an
investigation or anything like that
the real outcome was solved by one of
the worst things that has happened in
the racial history of the united states
the compromise of 1877
under which rutherford b hayes became
president of the united states despite
losing both the popular vote and
probably the electoral college vote
and republicans in exchange planned to
drop reconstruction efforts in the south
which led to essentially a century of
jim crow
later investigations by the way should
no wrong doing it by rutherford b hayes
it did show democratic attempts to bribe
election officials in disputed states
okay so you have this
mess of an election only solved by the
end of reconstruction essentially which
is not much of a solution
so they come up with the electoral count
act the electoral account act
of 1887 sets out the process that we
referred to before
which is that the vice president opens
these votes he counts the votes
and then a member of congress and a
senator can get together and challenge
the votes both houses
then recess to go debate it and then
they come back together and if both
votes of the congressional bodies decide
that they are going to
throw out votes from a particular state
because they're illegitimate or
something then they go ahead
and they do that and now even that
is not strict enough really okay because
the fact is that
the constitution was not really meant to
have a majority in congress
simply decide who the president of the
united states is
and that's that's really not what what
was supposed to happen here and that
would actually allow the federal
government to override state governments
the real question and this is what the
electoral account act says is you have
to have specific grounds for challenging
votes
one would be something like bribery of
electors and the second would be that
the governor did not certify the slate
of electors
right those would be the actual grounds
okay how do
slates of electors get certified so
according to section five of us
code title three this is passed in i
believe 1948 it says quote
if any state shall have provided by laws
enacted prior to the day fixed for the
appointment of the electors
for its final determination of any
controversy or contest concerning the
appointment
of all or any of the electors of such
state by judicial or other methods or
procedures
and such determination shall have been
made at least six days before the time
fixed for the meeting of the electors
such determination made pursuant to such
law so existing onset day made at least
six days
prior to set time of meeting the
electors shall be conclusive
and shall govern in the counting of the
electoral votes as provided in the
constitution
and as here and after regulated so far
as the ascertainment of the electors
appointed
by such state is concerned in other
words if a state takes advantage of the
safe harbor provision remember this we
discussed this late in december
if the safe harbor time hits okay which
is made
six days before the time fixed for the
meeting of the electors and the states
have certified their votes we are done
here okay now
challenges really are not relevant
because
at least when it comes to lawfully
certified in other words
once the governor says this is the slate
of electors and he does so within the
safe harbor period
these are now the electors okay and the
challenges to the electors cannot be
based
on whether they were quote unquote
lawfully certified it can only be based
on
regularly given right which would mean
normally bribery or fraud
okay so that is where things sort of
stand okay that is
that is the legal background for all of
this
okay so over the last couple of weeks
there's been growing momentum for
challenging electoral votes in congress
and the same way barbara boxer did in
uh in the same way that some congress
people did in 1969
and this has been led on the house side
by representative mo brooks of
alabama who said over the weekend that
they were gaining a lot of momentum he
said our fight for honest and accurate
elections
gains momentum jim jordan and i co-lead
conference call with 50 plus congressmen
who join and fight for america's
republic
morale is high fight okay so apparently
there are over 100 republican congress
people
who are joining on to this uh on to this
effort as chip roy of texas has pointed
out it's odd that all these congress
people who were literally elected in the
same election
in which they are now claiming that
electoral college votes should be thrown
out are challenging
the electoral college votes but not
their own election that's kind of a
weird thing i mean they were elected by
exactly the same ballots they're now
challenging
but the question is whether they have
any real serious legal grounds to do so
okay so preliminary question aside we'll
get back to that in a second the legal
grounds for this
on a strategic level this is not going
to work the reason this is not going to
work on a strategic level is perfectly
obvious the democrats control the house
so let's say that republicans challenge
these electoral college votes
in the house they get some senators like
josh halley and ted cruz and a lot of
people who i like right
steve daines a lot of people sign on to
this and then
the house is recess to discuss the votes
who thinks that the democratic house is
gonna be like you know what
after all we decided that we're gonna
just disregard you know what
slates of electors from pennsylvania
arizona georgia wisconsin
michigan nevada you know what you're
totally right you're 100 right
nancy pelosi is going to come forward
teeth the clack and be like donald trump
you're totally okay so that's not going
to happen right i mean let's just be
practical about this
that's not going to happen which means
the electoral votes don't get thrown out
end of story we're done here which
suggests
that this is really about one of two
things posturing by some people
because they want to appear that they
are fighting even though there really is
no available avenue left right the
election
is over it was over the day the
electoral college voted with certified
slate of electors
the certification process is a formality
it was always a formality
okay except since 1876
so the so instead what you are seeing
because
this in some cases it's either posturing
or it's an attempt to
fight voter fraud by drawing attention
to it is that this is what congress
people are saying
and so josh hawley puts out a statement
as the senator from missouri
who i think is pretty clearly attempting
to run for president in 2024 and capture
a lot of the the trump base so
he said here is his statement following
both the 2004 and 2016 elections
democrats in congress objected
during the certification of electoral
votes in order to raise concerns about
election integrity i mean it is true by
the way that some democrats in congress
tried to object
to certification of electoral votes
during the 2016 election
that was gaveled down by joe biden in
the senate right joe biden was the was
the vice president at the time
hallie said they were praised by
democratic leadership in the media when
they did
they were entitled to do so now those of
us concerned about the integrity of this
election are entitled to do the same
and you can i mean no one's saying you
can't try this i'm just saying it's not
really well legally predicated
and the basic model here which would be
that anytime you don't like the outcome
of an election
you and a majority of congress can
simply throw out all electoral college
votes
that is clearly not what the
constitutional structure was meant to
create
remember the electoral college is
supposed to represent the states
remember that not members of the federal
government not the popular vote
the point of the electoral college is
that the states are supposed to appoint
the electors
once the states have appointed the
electors the federal government does not
have cause
to simply throw out slates of electors
absent obvious evidence
of fraud that was not presented in court
here right because again court after
court many of them trump judges
said you're not even i mean the trump
team didn't even allege fraud in a lot
of these cases particularly like
pennsylvania
in any case haley says i cannot vote to
certify the electoral college results
on january 6th without raising the fact
that some states particularly
pennsylvania
failed to follow their own state
election laws okay so we'll get to this
argument in a second which is that
the electoral college vote from
pennsylvania should be thrown out
despite state certification because it
violates the federal constitution that's
argument that my friend mark levin makes
it's an interesting argument i disagree
with the legal analysis
haley says i cannot vote to certify
without pointing out the unprecedented
effort of mega corporations including
facebook and twitter
to interfere in the election in support
of joe biden okay that part is true but
you don't challenge electoral votes
because facebook and twitter were really
bad
those two things are completely
disconnected i totally agree
that facebook twitter big tech
social media the media itself we're
worth 10 points to joe biden in this
election there's no question about that
but that doesn't give you a legal
predicate for challenging electoral
college votes
in any case helly says for these reasons
i follow the same practice democrat
members of congress have in years pass
and object
during the certification process on
january 6th to raise these critical
issues
okay well then because hallie does that
right then because
josh halley has challenged the electoral
votes and you now have one senator that
was the question is whether one senator
would go along with members from the
house to actually jump into this process
because of that you see a lot of other
members of the senate
who again want to demonstrate field t to
trump and demonstrate fight and
demonstrate that they
don't like the outcome of the election
jumping on board again i don't think
there's a lot of legal basis to this as
i will explain
in just one second hey first let us talk
for a second about shopping for
auto parts so auto parts stores not my
cup of tea
don't love them i don't love them
because number one i'm not a car expert
i don't know much about my car number
two it's overpriced number three they
very often don't even have the parts and
have to order it online why not just
skip the middle man and go order the
part you need
online rockauto.com you have access to
rockauto.com at your desk and in your
pocket
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do why would you
spend
up to twice as much for the same part
rockauto.com it's a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
head on over to rockauto.com right now
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts and you're literally doing
that if you shop at these auto parts
stores as opposed to rockauto.com
they've got amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car is ever going to need rockauto.com
so head on over to rockauto.com right
now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck and then write shapiro in there
how did you hear about us box so they
know
that we sent you in the first place
helps them helps the show go check them
out right now rockauto.com right shapiro
and their how did you hear about us
box okay so when we get to more of the
legal analysis in just one second
because it's
it's kind of fascinating uh and we're
also going to get to the georgia race
there's a lot more to get to because
we're on break for like a week and a
half
first there are a million reasons that
people believe lies about conservatives
one of them is they've been trained to
do so by content creators that
absolutely
hate conservatives hate us right when
when you go to work people think
conservatives
are just bad people right when you when
you are on facebook
if you're conservative your friends
family coworkers they will treat you
as though you have some sort of brain
cancer if you say you're a conservative
why is this it's not just because of
political differences it's because
politics is downstream from culture as
my old mentor andrew breitbart
used to say as a culture we need content
that is edgy and entertaining and
awesome
but that does not mock conservative
values we need to give people options
daily wires aiming to do just that think
about this
fox news right everybody who's on the
right watches fox news
their their prime time lineup will
average 3.5 4 million people
there's 70 million subscribers to
netflix the vast majority of people's
politics
is not decided by politics it is decided
by cultural influences
outside of that it's decided by the
entertainment they consume and the music
they consume the movies and the tv they
consume if conservatives want to win in
the future we have to engage in the
culture war
in the culture it's called a culture war
because it's not just about voting it is
about the culture and that means
we have to provide an alternative to the
entertainment
left-wing cram-downs you see in places
like amazon prime
or places that you see like hulu or on
netflix you need
alternative sources of entertainment and
so do moderates
right things that they can see that are
fun and edgy
and yes somewhat conservative okay so
what you're about to watch
is an excerpt from daily wires first
motion picture film
is our first film ever from daily wire
we are getting into the space we need to
challenge
the big boys you want to win the culture
or you gotta fight in the culture
this film is called run hide fight it's
not a stereotypical conservative film in
fact
it's not particularly political at all
it is also not a family friendly film
okay
it is intense it is violent and it does
have a powerful message to go with it
the movie is about a high school
besieged by a quartet of school shooters
one young girl 17 year old zoe hull uses
her wits and survival skills
to fight back here is the trailer
in between breath take the shot
you're doing really good out there kid
size of that deer we're going to be
eating venison all summer
holidays work i think we need to see
somebody again and by
we mean me no i mean us hey that look in
your eye
guys in my evening at that location
maybe there's a brochure you can hand me
so i can go
is that chris angelic over there is he
doing something completely weird
senior prank day but we'll see all kinds
of dumb stuff today swim captain we'll
have thai food delivered to class and
becky vaughan will set up our homemade
slip and slide
this is high school nothing that happens
your matters in the real world
[Music]
okay we are in charge now so please pull
out whichever app you use to do live
streaming video get them up and running
and point it at me
now
get down on the ground any more friends
back there
i'm calling 911
you must be close
[Music]
you should be ashamed
very disturbing news out of vernon
central high school
[Music]
zoe
in between breath take a shot
go is it safe to say that this might be
our guardian angel
do you want more people to die that's
the last thing i want i'm gonna kill one
person in this room
every five minutes you don't show your
face
isn't it ironic that after all your hard
work
people aren't gonna remember you
no you're gonna remember me
the movie's badass okay the movie is
just it's excellent it is it is not for
younger audiences this would be a rated
r film for sure but that's the point
we are making rated our films right we
are making content
that are for that's for adults we are
making stuff that people want to see
right not just something where people
feel obligated to see it because
it promotes a particular world view
openly so that no moderate will ever see
it the point is that we are going to
change people's minds about issues by
providing them
cultural places where they can see that
conservatism
is not only not bad it is quite good and
we're going to be telling compelling
edgy stories to go with it we are really
pumped to show you this film
and bring you something that's never
been done before in conservative media
never been done
we need your help run hide fight will be
available to watch friday january 15th
my birthday
at dailywire.com we'll be doing a
special live stream premiere
the night before thursday january 14th
on the daily wire youtube channel
so let's kick off 2021 by fighting back
on culture we've got to fight the
culture war we need to create our own
content and we need your help
we need you to join up at dailywire.com
this content is not cheap to produce
it is really important there's a reason
democrats pour billions of dollars
into film and tv they know what
convinces people we need to do the same
thing
check us out at dailywire.com go
subscribe right now and you can see
run hide fight which is just a badass
awesome movie you're gonna love it
i can't wait to show really i'm very
eager to show it to you so come join us
over at dailywire you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
all right so josh halley signifies that
he is going to join mo brooks and he is
going to
challenge these electoral college
results and he says that he wants to do
so in order to put
a spotlight on what has happened in
pennsylvania and on allegations of voter
fraud and also on big tax so
yeah again i think that what he says
about big tech is 100 right i don't know
what it has to do with challenging
electoral college
votes so this prompts a bunch of other
republican senators to jump on board
including
senators ted cruz ron johnson james
lankford steve daines john kennedy
marsha blackburn mike braun senators
elect cynthia loomis from wyoming roger
marshall of kansas bill hagerty of
tennessee and tommy tuberville
of alabama and they put out a statement
it said the election of 2020 like the
election of 2016 was hard fought and in
many swing states
narrowly decided the 2020 election
however featured unprecedented
allegations of voter fraud violations
and lacks enforcement of election law
and other voting irregularities now the
the problem here of course
is that when you say that it featured
unprecedented allegations you actually
if you're going to challenge electoral
college votes you actually have to show
unprecedented
unprecedented evidence right
unprecedented allegations i mean
we can run democrats do unprecedented
allegations and i will point this out
here too i mean democrats did
unprecedented allegations for four years
they claimed that donald trump was a
russian tool
and vladimir putin had hired trump
basically to become president of the
united states
and that trump had gained the office
simply by cooperating with vlad
so that was an unprecedented allegation
turns out they didn't have unprecedented
proof and so
it came to nothing but when democrats
complain that allegations are not
sufficient
and take that with a grain of salt
whenever it's a democrat pushing
allegations the allegations are
sufficient
i would hope that conservatives are a
little bit more consistent that
allegations are never sufficient
you need actual evidence to back the
allegations whether we are talking about
bull crap about brett kavanaugh or
bullcrap about the covington catholic
kids or whether you're talking about
bull crap
about systemic american racism like
actual evidence would be necessary not
just allegations so it's not enough to
say unprecedented
allegations of voter fraud you actually
have to show proof
but say these senators the allegations
are not believed just by one individual
candidate
they are widespread because 67 percent
of republicans say the election was
rigged and so do 17
of democrats and 31 percent of
independents he says some members
these are all the senators on the
republican side who are going along with
the challenge
some members of congress disagree with
that assessment as do many members of
the media
but whether or not our elected officials
or journalists believe it that deep
distrust of our democratic processes
will not magically disappear it should
concern us all it poses an ongoing
threat to the legitimacy of all
subsequent
administrations okay so let's just be
straight about this
all those doubts are not going to go
away because congress
has a two-hour session where they yell
at each other that's not going to happen
and they're not going to go away
if there's some sort of jointly
appointed electoral commission which is
what
crews at all are calling for right they
are calling for a
following of the 1877 president now
remember the electoral count act was
designed explicitly to avoid
the 1877 commission
because that commission it turned out
was completely partisan and not only was
it completely partisan the only way that
that crisis ended up being resolved was
the end of reconstruction so it wasn't
like that was a wildly great
precedent to set and then it worked
fantastic so we should go back to that
but they're calling for an electoral
investigation they'll take 10 days
now let's be real about that who thinks
that at the end of 10 days everybody who
was who was disquieted about the
rather serious allegations of voter
fraud and irregularity are going to be
oh you know they took 10 days
i mean they took a whole 10 days now i
feel better not going to happen
obviously okay so so just on a practical
level it's not going to quell fears
it is not going to end the way that
republicans want it to end because
democrats control
the house so that's just not going to
happen nonetheless vice president
pence's chief of staff said that he
welcomed the effort by some lawmakers to
raise objections
mark short said vice president pence
shares the concerns of millions of
americans about voter fraud and
regularity
and therefore welcomes the effort of
members of the house and senate to use
the authority they have under the law to
raise objections and bring forward
evidence now
listen again they can do that they can
raise objections bring forward evidence
it's not going to be practical
and it's not going to end with any
change here senator tom cotton who again
is a very pro-trump senator
right cotton is really a pro-trump guy
from arkansas
he put out a statement on why he was not
going to join these efforts
and i think this is systemically correct
the point that he's making is you don't
want to set the precedent
whereby the congress of the united
states decides to completely
overlook the certified electoral college
results in various states
in favor of simply ruling at the federal
level which votes should be counted
which votes should not
that's a huge mistake especially because
let's just on a practical level point
something out
republicans since 1992 since 19 well
sorry since 1988 republicans have won
the popular vote a ground total of one
time
once since 1988 since i was four years
old republicans have won the popular
national vote
in a presidential election one time so
republicans rightly
are big fans of the electoral college i
think on a systemic level they should be
big fans of the electoral college
because i think the states should have a
say
in who gets to be president but that's
the point if you have congress
overruling the states not on the basis
of proved fraud
not on the basis of proved voter
irregularity but on the basis they don't
like the results you're setting the
precedent whereby
in four years vice president kamala
harris
decides after she loses right let's say
that biden
let's say that biden is on his last legs
harris runs to succeed him
and now you have her ruling at the top
of the senate
on her own loss and simply saying you
know what i won the popular vote
the electoral college count doesn't
matter anymore republicans made clear
that last time we're done
i win how's that going to go is that
going to go great i don't think so it's
setting a very very
very negative legal precedent here that
is going to be extraordinarily
counterproductive
and by the way is not going to end with
trump retaining the office of the
presidency
again democrats in the house would have
to agree with republicans in the senate
to throw out electoral college votes
which is not going to happen
so it is bad law it is bad policy
and it is not effective in any real
sense
which means that it's kind of virtue
signaling unless people
actually think it's going to work for
some odd reason that i can't comprehend
like there's no way this works it's just
not going to work
okay so tom cotton makes this clear
again cotton is very this is not about
opposing trump or not opposing trump
this is about recognizing that there are
consequences to messing around with the
legal system
i didn't just vote for trump i stumped
for trump i told you why you should vote
for trump
i i'm quite upset with the outcome of
the election tom cotton is quite upset
with the outcome of the election
that doesn't mean that what we are now
pursuing here is a good policy or
effective policy
so cotton put out a statement he said
quote i share the concerns of many
arkansans about irregularities in the
presidential election
especially in states that rushed through
election law changes to relax standards
of voting by mail
i also share their disappointment with
the election results i therefore support
a commission
to study the last election and propose
reforms to protect the integrity of our
elections
and after republicans win in georgia the
senate should also hold more hearings on
these matters
nevertheless the founders entrusted our
elections chiefly to the states not
congress
they entrusted the election of our
president to the people acting through
the electoral college
not congress they entrusted the
adjudication of election disputes to the
courts
not congress under the constitution and
federal law congress's power is limited
to counting electoral votes submitted by
the states
correct if congress purported to
overturn the results of the electoral
college it would not only exceed that
power it would establish unwise
precedence
first congress would take away the power
to choose the president from the people
which would essentially end presidential
elections and place that power in the
hands of whichever party controls
congress
second congress would imperil the
electoral college itself which gives
small states like arkansas a voice in
presidential elections
democrats could achieve their
long-standing goal of eliminating the
electoral college in effect
by refusing to count electoral votes in
the future for a republican
president-elect
third congress should take another big
step toward federalizing election law
another long-standing democratic
priority that republicans have
consistently opposed
okay so cotton happens to be legally
correct about all of this right this is
this is right
cotton's explanation is correct okay so
that leaves one outstanding legal debate
that is interesting on an intellectual
and a legal level
so mark levin friend of mine really good
guy
really obviously terrific conservative
who's done enormous work
in convincing americans why conservatism
is a good idea
so late in in the year uh he put out a
ap's
trying to explain why electoral
challenges were a good idea
particularly with regard to the
pennsylvania vote
so here's what he says he says
specifically article 2 section 1 clause
2 of the federal constitution
could not be more explicit it states in
pertinent part each state shall appoint
in such manner as the legislature
thereof made iraq
a number of electors equal to the whole
number of senators and representatives
to which the state
may be entitled in the congress this
language was purposeful
during the constitutional convention
there were various proposals suggested
for electing a president
should the president be directly elected
that proposal was rejected
because the founders feared a purely
democratic process could be hijacked by
a temporary
majority should the president be chosen
from within the national legislature
that proposal was also rejected should
the judiciary play a role
that idea was rejected the electoral
process rested first and foremost
on the state legislatures directing how
the electors would be chosen
the reason while rejecting the direct
election of a president the framers
concluded that the state legislatures
were closest to the people okay so
basically he is saying that because
pennsylvania did the wrong process
for putting together their voting
procedure because courts
and the governor intervened in the
process that this means
that the entire state electoral college
vote should be thrown out
because the federal government is
empowered with ensuring that each state
appoints in such a manner as a
legislature direct
a number of electors on the face that
makes some sense right i mean
that the state the constitution says
state legislatures have to decide the
process
and in pennsylvania it was not state
legislatures that were deciding
the process and the problem is that a
bunch of courts have already decided
that this is
not correct interpretation and in fact
the the actual meaning of the
constitution here is relatively clear
what it means
is that the electoral college is decided
by the state legislature the legislature
decides
exactly the the manner in which
the electoral college is is
selected but it doesn't mean that they
have to be in charge of every single
detail
okay so for example there was a there
was a judge okay
a recent trump appointee named brett
ludwig okay and he ruled specifically on
this argument
and here's what he said as used in the
electors clause the word manner refers
to the form or method of selection of
the presidential electors
it requires state legislatures merely to
set the approach for selecting
presidential electors
put another way it simply refers to the
mode of appointing electors consistent
with the plan meeting
with the plain meaning of the term so
what does that mean
it means that you could have chosen to
appoint electors directly
right the state legislature could just
select the electors or the state
legislature could do it by congressional
district
or they could simply have the governor
appoint the electors but once they
decide
then they decide right the approach form
method or mode
that a legislature sets for appointing
presidential electors is by general
ballot at the general election
okay so the same logic applies in
pennsylvania
right here here is what the judge said
in this particular case he said issues
of mere administration of a general
election do not mean
there has not been a general ballot at a
general election
plaintiff's conflation of these
potential non-conformities with
constitutional violations
is contrary to the plain meaning of the
elector's clause
if a plaintiff's reading of manner was
correct any disappointed loser in a
presidential election able to hire a
team of clever lawyers could flag
claim deviations from the election rules
and cast out on the election results in
other words
the pennsylvania state legislature said
that the popular vote of the state of
pennsylvania was going to decide the
outcome
okay then counties went ahead and did a
bunch of different procedures for
gathering the popular vote
a lawyer could simply say well the
legislature didn't decide how that was
going to happen so therefore the process
is broken and you can throw out those
state electors
okay that that is not what the
constitution means in this particular
circumstance i don't think i understand
where mark is coming from i don't think
that that is correct
and again i think that it sets the
federal government over
these states as to how they actually do
their election processes
which is a mistake you don't want the
federal government actually doing that
because the federal government could be
controlled by democrats
guys as david french points out and this
is
this is a good point it is quite
possible that then democrats can object
to texas's electoral votes for trump
because texas governor greg abbott
invoked emergency powers to modify
statutory restrictions regarding the
delivery of mail-in ballots
right so the legislature didn't actually
decide how the vote went in texas either
okay so this is the um this is
sort of the the contrary argument uh to
what
uh mark has been arguing again i i i
think mark's argument is interesting i
don't think that it is uh
fully convincing to me at least
meanwhile andrew mccarthy again a big
ally of trump he has a long piece today
about this process as he points out the
law
makes pretty clear that once the state
certifications are done they are now
conclusive says danny mccarthy it is not
a matter of whether it is the result we
would have preferred
or even whether it is a result we
suspect it is the law this undeniable
fact has been recognized by seven
federal judges including judges recently
appointed by trump
who've examined the trump claims
rejected them and disclaimed any
authority under the circumstances to
disturb the state's determinations
if despite all of that democrats were
trying to orchestrate a congressional
do-over republicans would be pointing
out
with due indignation the constitution
that makes the election of a president
like the ratification of the
constitution a matter of state
sovereignty
under our foundational law it is the
states not the people not congress
that determine which candidates are
receiving electoral votes
the 12th amendment requires that the
count has to be done in the presence of
lawmakers
over which the vice president presides
but
this sort of power grab is really not
justifiable under the
constitution or under prevailing law
says andy mccarthy
and this this seems correct not only
that but it's pretty obviously gonna
fail even if you agree
with the argument that there's solid
legal grounds for challenging these
electoral results
democrats control the house they're not
going to vote to throw out electoral
college votes in these various states so
when people say the reason i'm spending
a lot of time on this is because there
are a lot of folks who seem to want to
turn this into some sort of conservative
litmus test
like if you're truly conservative you're
a true believer then you
will will back these electoral college
challenges i think that
there's a fairly solid conservative case
so i say fairly solid conservative case
to be made they're actually undermining
a bunch of fundamental principles that
you are going to be sad you undermine in
five minutes
and when you say that the federal
government should have the capacity to
simply throw
out electoral college votes on any basis
they want essentially without providing
proper evidence
that is not a precedent you want to set
republicans in presidential elections
have traditionally relied on the
electoral college to provide them
victory
again considering that since 1988 one
election 2004 has been a popular vote
victory for a republican
and you need that electoral college
you're going to miss it when it's gone
so don't screw around with this process
it is a mistake
it is also a mistake to make this the
paramount consideration
considering that there is an actual big
election coming up this week the
election of 2020 happened in 2020 it is
now 2021.
in the next two days there is a massive
election as in tomorrow there is a
massive election in georgia
that election is going to decide control
of the senate
regardless of what sort of processes are
attempted in the next week regardless of
the political positioning of various
senators or congress people
joe biden will be certified the winner
of the election he already was by these
various states
okay so now the question becomes what's
going to happen in the senate just on a
practical level
what's going to happen in the senate and
the answer is
if democrats take the senate it's going
to be a full-on disaster area
republicans in georgia get out and vote
get out and vote
by the way not just me saying this trump
is saying this his kids are saying this
his team is saying this get out and vote
you need to vote in georgia you cannot
hand control of the senate over to
kamala harris and joe biden that's nuts
there is no rationale whatsoever for
handing over two senate seats to rafael
warnock
a marxist radical and john ossoff a
trust fund socialist
don't do it don't i mean so david perdue
who is uh who did beat john ossoff uh in
or or yeah he'd be john ossoff by about
80 000 votes in the last go round he
just missed
by a few by a few votes finishing above
that 50
mark that would have sent him back to
the senate purdue said over the weekend
if the democrats are in charge america
is not going to be the same that is
correct the bulwark
against joe biden and kamala harris is
going to be a republican senate do not
blow it guys here was purdue's ad over
the weekend
now we take georgia and then we change
america
to make sure that we don't have a
republican senate majority
so that we don't have to negotiate when
we win these two seats
plus come over harris breaking the time
it'll be like getting
60 votes when we take back the senate
and have the majority
we will have a lot to do total
democratic control
that's their goal if they're in charge
america will never be the same
save america vote for david perdue on
january 5th
okay and the media are all in all in on
on john ossoff i mean they are they are
all in on assaf they're all in on
raphael warnock they are they are going
at it with it with a vengeance
i mean it's it's amazing it's amazing
how hard
they are they're going for the democrats
so raphael warnock
who was uh in this this runoff right i
mean ossoff is with purdue and warnock
is running against uh
kelly lefler so raphael warnock is
getting just the the golden treatment
from the media here's a headline from
the new york times about rafael warnock
a racial radical who has said openly
anti-semitic things
was praised jeremiah wright who has
praised louis farrakhan
who has who did groundwork for a church
visit from fidel castro
okay this nut job who by the way
was briefly arrested for obstruction
over investigation of child abuse at a
summer camp back in the 90s
and then later he was uh he was released
and cleared
who's whose ex-wife suggested that he
ran over his foot with a car
her foot with a car and that uh and that
he was a liar and all of this
that guy is being treated with just the
greatest
the greatest sort of kid gloves by the
media here's a headline from the new
york times
you ready raphael warnock from the
pulpit to politics doesn't shy from
uncomfortable truths
wow what a hero what a hero now well
that seems to me defending jeremiah
wright's not uncomfortable truth it's
you being a jackass but
according to the media this makes you a
powerful voice a powerful
voice i mean just just incredible
so the new york times goes on and on
about what a magical magical man raphael
warnock is
the washington post has a piece i mean
this is all timed the media are just
disgusting i mean they're disgustingly
partisanly biased and in an insane way
they did cost trump the election no
doubt okay
lifestyle the lifestyle section of the
washington post lifestyle not an opinion
piece lifestyle
raphael warnock's campaign for the moral
high ground
what an amazing man he is he's so
amazing
for the past 15 years warnock has been
the senior pastor at the storied
ebenezer baptist church in atlanta the
same church once led by his hero martin
luther king jr the flamboyant
preacher paul style were not cultivated
maybe alien to many americans including
many white christians but it is deeply
familiar to those who grew up
in and around southern black churches in
those churches preachers make it their
business to tell
uncomfortable truths about american life
including the shameful ways the country
treats
its african american citizens what what
a hero
what a hero he is meanwhile the media
will just allow the democrats to lie
about republicans over and over and over
again
so for example john ossoff suggested
that
republican kelly lefler has been
campaigning with a klansman
that is just a lie it's an overt lie
kelly lefler has taken pictures of
thousands of people
one of the people she took pictures with
was a klansman she didn't know the guy
from adam
doesn't matter john ossoff just goes on
national tv and lies about it he has not
received one iota of blowback from the
same media who claim they are guardians
of the truth because in fact they're not
they're just guardians of democrats
here's the bottom line kelly lefler has
been campaigning with a klansman
kelly lefler has been campaigning with a
klansman
and so she is stooping to these vicious
personal attacks
to distract from the fact that she's
been campaigning with a former member of
the ku klux klan
i mean we deserve better than that here
in georgia okay that is just a lie it's
just a lie it isn't any fact check this
out on the front page of the atlanta
journal constitution
here's kelly lafleur slapping the
pathological liar john ossoff
georgia knows that jon ossoff is a
pathological liar he's a trust fund
socialist whose only job has been
working for the chinese communist party
in recent years
and look here's the deal if we're going
to tell lies about my campaign let's
tell the truth about who
he's campaigning with this is the truth
radical liberal raphael warnock
has been involved in child abuse
domestic abuse so i'm not going to be
lectured by some 33 year old
trust fund socialist who's a
pathological liar
okay i mean she's right about this it's
amazing how ossoff and warren i mean
the the media are trying to cram the
democrats into power they're trying to
do it if you're in georgia do not sit
out the election
i know you're pissed about what happened
in 2020. i know you are turn the page
because
what's coming next is gonna be a lot lot
worse if democrats take control
of the united states senate by the way
speaking of just the media being a
bag of garbage a couple of quick bag of
garbage media stories for you
here right now okay so bag of garbage
media story number one
so remember that time when we were told
that california is just wonderful with
covet
california is doing great i lived in la
until very very recently
and la was just it was wonderful they
shut down everything you couldn't go
outdoor dining you couldn't hike you
couldn't do a bunch of stuff for months
at a time and they did an amazing job
they crushed the curve right i mean they
just did an amazing amazing job
uh there is only one problem uh in fact
they did not do an amazing job
you can crush the curve but it turns out
the curve then crushes you
because if you decide on wide scale
lockdown
then when people go out they will infect
each other at extraordinary rates and
that's exactly what has been happening
in la county which now posted its third
highest single day total for coronavirus
cases on new year's reporting 19 000
cases
that means that over the last seven days
there's an average of more than 16 000
new coveted cases a day reported in the
county about 12
times bigger than the comparable figure
from november 1st and the highest figure
ever recorded the tally reported friday
pushed the average number of new daily
coveted cases over the last week to over
16 000
precisely around the same time
epidemiologists warn people infected
around the christmas holiday would begin
to become infectious the hospitals are
being overwhelmed they're being overrun
in l.a county it is a full-scale
disaster area speaking of full-scale
disaster areas
the growth of covet again in new york is
getting pretty severe
and uh andrew cuomo has an idiotic plan
so this
bag of tools he's just this awful awful
governor
who presided over the worst death rate
in the united states with the exception
of new jersey
right just a horror horrifying death
rate tens of thousands of dead
in his state because he decided to ship
the elderly back into nursing homes with
covet
this awful awful governor who suggested
for months that he didn't trust a
vaccine developed under the trump
administration
now this guy is blowing it when it comes
to tranching out the vaccine
so here's how we should be trenching out
the vaccine okay because these things
have expiration dates once they're out
of the fridge
they're out of the fridge the way that
it should work is that everybody who's
elderly gets a shot
everybody who's elderly gets a shot and
if you hit the end of the day and there
ain't nobody elderly around you
inoculate anybody who's there
because you don't want to waste the
doses right because once they're out of
the fridge
they're done right so you want it better
that somebody who is not in line
should get the shot then that somebody
doesn't get the shot
who's not in line right like wasting
doses is idiotic it makes no sense at
all
and in fact there are lots of countries
that have been doing this exactly right
israel is an
excellent example over a million people
have already been vaccinated in israel
they have drive-through lines
you literally just get in your car you
drive to one of these drive-throughs and
you get the shot
okay here in florida there have been
people lining up
at places where the shots are available
they're not wasting shots
so andrew cuomo's plan however is he is
so interested in the quote-unquote
prioritization
because he wants i don't know racial
equity
achieved via the inoculation of
essential workers who are
disproportionately minority or some such
nonsense he is actually threatening to
fine people
millions of dollars if they take the
vaccine
out of order so he would rather that
vaccine doses be spoiled
and they go to somebody out of order
here is this dolt who's been treated
as the godsend of covid treatment here
here's this
andrew cuomo i'm going to sign an
executive order
that says we're very clear
the vaccines are a priority there's not
going to be any
politics at play as to who gets a
vaccine
and we look to the cdc federal
government for guidance
and we will not tolerate
any fraud in the vaccination process
anyone who engages in fraud
is going to be held accountable the
executive order i'm going to sign today
says a provider could be fined up to a
million dollars
and revocation of all state licenses
okay so if you're knowingly not eligible
right you come to the end of the day
there's nobody in line
and there's a janitor there and he wants
the vaccine you give him the janitor he
wants to find you a million dollars and
revoke your certification
this is a recipe for losing doses of the
vaccine idiocy
and that guy give that guy an emmy makes
perfect sense to me follow the science
the science speaking of which quick
scientific note the state of california
apparently over the uh over the holiday
they moved to change insurance language
on double mastectomy
for gender dysphoric females from
cosmetic to reconstructive
to ensure no age limit for the procedure
okay so if you're a woman and you
believe that you're a male
and you want to have double mastectomies
right you want to cut off your breasts
now to make sure that insurance
companies cover it they are suggesting
that your breasts are i'm not kidding
you this is how california now describes
normal human female breasts you ready
quote abnormal structures of the body
caused by congenital defects
that's right you don't have a condition
called gender dysphoria what you have is
an abnormal body
your body is abnormal for having grown
in direct relation to its genetic
source your breasts are now abnormal
structures of the body caused by
congenital defects trust the science
guys
trust the science i think that these
people have everything uh well
in hand well in hand okay final note on
the media i would be remiss if i didn't
cover the story because it did again
blow up over the break i know there's a
long show today but
we missed about a week and a half of
news so the new york times continues
to promulgate cancel culture in
extraordinary ways in extraordinary ways
so dan levine had a piece over the over
the holiday that's just
insane it was called a racial slur a
viral video and a reckoning
a white high school student withdrew
from her chosen college after a three
second video caused an uproar online
the classmate who shared it publicly has
no regrets
so what exactly is this story this shows
you how far our culture is is trashed
that's why we gotta fight back in the
culture guys because our culture is
trashed
according to the new york times this is
a multiple thousand word story from the
new york times quote
jimmy galligan was in history class last
school year when his phone buzz with the
message
once he clicked on it he found a three
second video of a white classmate
looking into the camera and uttering
an anti-black racial slur the slur he
said was regularly hurled in classrooms
and hallways throughout his years
in the loudoun county school district he
brought up the issue to teachers and
administrators but much to his anger and
frustration
his complaints had gone nowhere okay so
he held on to the video and then he made
a decision that would ricochet around
leesburg virginia
a town named for an ancestor of the
confederate general robert e lee okay
they're going to try and connect a 15
year old girl to robert e lee by the
name of the town this is
excellent journalism here from the new
york times quote is from
galligan whose mother is black and
father is white
i wanted to get her where she would
understand the severity of that word
he tucked the video away deciding to
post it publicly when the time was right
okay so this guy's a sociopath a
sociopath
okay it is a sociopathic behavior to
when you're 15 years old
tuck away a video of a person who is 15
year old who's 17 i guess and this kid
was 15.
tuck away the video of a 15 year old to
wreck her life
because she said and i'm kidding you
this is what she said was she's driving
right for the first time
she looked into a camera and said i can
drive n word
but the n word was not like
with the er at the end it was with the
ah
right like he commonly used n-word in
rap music which again is gross and there
shouldn't be a distinction but there is
that double standard
she obviously did not mean it as a
racial slur against black people
okay that's perfectly obvious from the
video she's a 15 year old girl who's
doing the rap
thug life kind of crap that the media
have decided it's actually a good idea
for people to do
okay so she does that this sociopathic
kid
decides to hold back that video until
the girl is admitted
to college and then to release it online
to get her thrown out of college
and the new york times cheers this as a
reckoning
as a reckoning they want to ruin your
life
they want to the media want to ruin your
life they want
every facebook thing you have ever put
up every tweet you have ever said
anything you have ever uttered to be on
tape so they can hold it back and then
use it as a club against you to ruin
your life when the time is right
and to teach a broader lesson what
brother lesson was taught other than
this kid is a jerk and the new york
times is disgusting
galligan had not seen the video before
receiving it last school year by which
time he and groves were seniors by then
she was a varsity cheer captain who
dreamed of attending university of
tennessee knoxville
whose cheer team was reigning national
champion when she made the team in may
her parents celebrated with a cake and
orange balloons according to the
university
uh the university's official color the
next month as protests were sweeping the
nation
groves in a public instagram post urged
people to protest donate sign a petition
rally and do something
in support of blm and then galligan
released the video
so she did the liberal woke signaling
and he said no
no no here's a video of you doing a bad
thing that i'm going to deliberately
interpret
as racist and then i'm going to ruin
your life because you said that you were
in favor of blm
and the new york times cheers it cheers
it
gross was removed from the university
cheer team she withdrew from the school
under pressure from admissions officials
she was among many incoming freshmen
across the country whose admissions
offers were revoked by at least a dozen
universities after videos emerged on
social media
this is the culture the left wants to
create this is the culture war
it should be fought at every single turn
and the media
you gotta replace them is why should
subscribe to daily wire we're trying to
replace them these jackasses should not
have any power disgusting from the new
york times disgusting from that fellow
student gross all the way around
all right we'll be back here today with
an additional hour of the venture bureau
show in the meantime
go check out the michael knowles show on
today's episode mike will be talking
about cops invading homes to break up
new year's parties
that's the thing that was actually
happening that episode is available
right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2020.
if you want to cut through the madness
of our politics and culture and know
what's really going on
head on over to the michael knowles show
where we can all bask in the simple joys
of being right
see you there